la atención en la liga árabe estaba
puesta por el regreso del sirio vallar
al azar a la Cumbre Después de 12 años
sin embargo recibieron una sorpresiva
visita del presidente ucraniano
antes de participar en el g7 selenkin se
dirigió a los referentes del mundo árabe
solicitando apoyo en la guerra
no tenemos misiles como los tiene
nuestro enemigo tenemos menos poder
aéreo no poseemos numerosos drones
asesinos que Irán suministra a Rusia no
tenemos tanta artillería pero nos
mantenemos fuertes porque tenemos la
verdad en nuestro lado además estamos
expulsando a los ocupantes de nuestra
tierra
y en el jefe de estado ucraniano criticó
la postura de los Países Árabes Quienes
se han mantenido neutrales e incluso
algunos tienen lazos cercanos con Moscú
como Arabia Saudita que en septiembre
pasado logró la liberación de 10
prisioneros extranjeros capturados en
Rusia
estoy seguro de que todos podemos estar
Unidos para salvar a la gente de las
jaulas de las prisiones rusas
Lamentablemente hay algunos en el mundo
y aquí entre ustedes que hacen la vista
gorda ante esas jaulas y anexiones
ilegales
tras su alocución Selene informó que le
daría la liga árabe su plan de paz en
tanto que Arabia Saudita se ofreció a
mediano entre las partes
riad ha ganado influencia a nivel global
haciendo valer su posición como máximo
exportador petrolero siendo importante
tanto para Moscú como para Estados
Unidos